and i'm excited because um it's
beautiful
love is beautiful and so is ariana
grande's new
engagement ring yeah ari announced her
engagement to boyfriend dalton gomez on
instagram over the weekend
writing forever and then some he popped
the question about nine months after
they started dating it was like so crazy
and check out this closer look of that
ring
some estimate that it's five carats and
worth around
two hundred thousand dollars and that
pearl well it might be a nod
to this post ariana made back in 2014
a sign of protection for the star a
source tells et that the pair
are madly in love and very serious about
each other
so who is dalton he's an la-based real
estate agent
and our source says ari also admires how
successful and hardworking he is in his
own career
but also likes that he is down to earth
and is a regular guy
you might think i'm crazy the way i've
been craving
if i put it quite plainly just give me
the baby
the 34 plus 35 singer first won
instagram official with her man
in june posting this pic and our source
says the couple has been talking about
taking next steps
for a while oh my god it's a gift and
it's a joy ari also put her man in her
stuck with you music video with justin
bieber
[Music]
of course ariana was previously linked
to the late mac miller
and was engaged to pete davidson in 2018
though they called it off five months
later the exes
inspired this breakup anthem
[Music]
in may a source told et that after so
many high-profile relationships she
wanted to keep things with dalton
quote more private ari's mom is clearly
thrilled commenting so so
so happy love you too demi lovato also
commented writing
this ring is everything and scooter
braun
sent this message of support quote
congrats to these two amazing souls
ari we love you and could not be happier
for you
dalton you are a lucky man